if you're looking for ways to find your
passion be a minimalist and empower
others than this video is for you when
you love something every day goes by in
10 minutes and for me it was all about
fashion right now the minimalism clears
my head it represents Who I am if you
encourage women to explore their own
creativity and hopefully you give them
the tools they can express themselves
the motivation whattcha top 10 with
believe nation what's up it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out onto the world so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a woman who
tried and failed to make the US Olympic
team for Figure Skating to becoming an
award-winning fashion designer with
clients like Mariah Carey Victoria
Beckham and Kim Kardashian she's Vera
Wang and here's my take on her top 10
Rose a success
enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one
find your passion I was working as a
salesgirl at nice al-haram and in walk
Frances Pataca Stein
she was then the fashion director of
American Vogue I sold her a lot of
clothes she said someday when you finish
college call me and I will give you a
job at Vogue well for me safety of quoi
and I came on when I told my mother this
woman's gonna give me a job at Vogue and
my mother started laughing at me she
said I'm sure she says that to all the
young women and I said no I I think she
really thinks that I can come to Vogue
and work I didn't know what an editor
did I think she saw a passion and I
think she saw a desire to work I got
totally seduced and from there on in I
fell in love with it and it just became
it became my life fashion is not for the
faint of heart
not just figure skating by the way and
considering those who this to loves of
my life I would say that in order to do
both and suffer in a way sometimes the
loneliness of that kind of dedication
and you have to really be passionate
when you love something every day goes
by in 10 minutes
and for me it was all about fashion it
really was it was my way to express
myself through dressing women and
creating things and that's a very very
seductive feeling you know it was just
you know when you look at the clock and
your clock watcher and it's nine o'clock
and you look again it's 9:02 and you
look again it's nine seven well when I
worked at Vogue I'd look at 9:02 or 802
and I'd look again it was 10:00 at night
and I don't even know where my youth are
my days or my nights went well you're 15
years but I was I was really really very
very happy there rule number two is be
fearless one of the things that I found
extremely fascinating about you is that
you and your career have consistently
been a risk taker in fact I think one of
the biggest risks you took was turning
the traditional white bridal gown into
pink yellow green even black what drove
you to take such risks well I will say I
am fairly fearless although it doesn't
come without a price but creatively and
when you work in a certain genre and I
work in ready to wear as well as Bridal
but I think we're very celebrated
obviously for the dress for the woman's
most important day of her life so I have
to say that trying to keep that fresh
trying to keep that new trying to keep
myself creative and trying to envision
Bridal as a whole nother form trying to
visually brought us a whole other form
of self-expression for not only myself
as a designer but for the bride I'm
taking big risks like black dresses new
dresses pink dresses rule number three
is marry your creativity with business I
think the perception of fashion is that
it's extremely glamorous and that it's
sort of frivolous and all of these
things but it really isn't like it's
like a business like anything else and
have to pardon my punks I'm known for
wedding but you have to marry really
your creativity with what's going on and
what's real in terms of the market rule
number four is reinvent yourself tending
Sarah Lawrence to provided a general
opportunity for me to pursue my Olympic
dream while attempting to get a serious
liberal arts education in the end I
neither qualified for the US Olympic
team nor excelled at college and
ultimately Sarah Lawrence asked me to
take an indefinite leave of absence in
other words I was kicked out I was now
at an all-time low more than my family
and faculty I had let myself down
morally spiritually and intellectually
as I slowly and painfully began to
reevaluate my decisions I found great
solace in Paris where I fell in love
with fashion it was the first time in my
life I had lived not lived the
overschedule existence of a professional
child in addition to immersing myself in
French culture I also reaffirm my own
desire to return to school skating for
me had not ended with Olympic gold but
it provided me with a powerful metaphor
that would forever define my life no
matter how many times you fall get up
and try again getting back in a Sarah
Lawrence now became my overriding goal
metaphorically at 20 I was starting out
all over again although my second
attempt at college was very different
this time I was fully committed to
learning but also determined to explore
life from a very different perspective I
had also learned yet another significant
life lesson about the importance of
timing and priorities but most of all
reinvention as jr. your approach I again
returned to Paris from Rouen Sarah
Laurance international program what a
magical time that was
and as I felt further in love with all
things French not men necessarily oh
maybe a life and fashion began to
intrigue me I had found something else
that had seduced my heart and captured
my imagination as much as skating hat
rule number five work in a great
environment vote was my first job and I
was very very lucky to have a job there
everything I've learned a lot of my
training my eye my background has come
from my years of voc and I think working
for Ralph Lauren was a privilege in all
honesty when you work for a man that's
so decisive so consistent so brilliant
it's bound to or hopefully to influence
how you view your own career and so I
was very fortunate to have two really
great careers of both of these
institutions rule number six find your
creative process when I first started I
used to do sketches where I could say
well here's a low neck here's a high
neck here's a birch I'm fat with a
bigger skirt I mean it was the only way
I could get out what was in my brain but
over the last 25 years I've really come
to want to work myself with the fabric
so being here is now integral to my
design process there's no other place or
way I can do it anymore
it sounds very extravagant in this day
and age but we work right on the body
and we have a constant model because I
have to see the clothing on the body
very interested you're a rattlin I don't
want to tear this one apart
another write that goes away i draped on
her I correct it
I make them cut it we do pages of notes
I want to space I could in a way retire
from the intensity of that room which is
extremely intense so this room is my
office if that's the right word no one
comes in here it's really for me my
Haven slash disco flash house mental
hospital rule number seven is learned
from failure also behind every perceived
success is always some very significant
failure the importance of failure
however as many people say is to learn
from it but to quote Winston Churchill
success is not final and failure is not
fatal
it is a courage to continue that counts
rule number eight work hard on your
passion if you could credit your success
to just one thing what would that be I
would think hard work also very Chinese
trait in all fairness I was driven by
passion I think whenever I speak to
young people I always try to instigate
in them and understanding that if you
really feel something for something if
you really love something you're going
to succeed for more easily rule number
nine is be a minimalist if you didn't
know Vera Wang was a top fashion
designer before walking into her new
office space you'd be none the wiser
once you were there there are no racks
of clothes no swatches of fabric or even
glossy high-fashion photography on the
wall the space is so spare there isn't
even a sign at the entrance for me right
now
there's my head it represents Who I am
today probably even more than as a
designer because there's so many
categories technically I have to do so I
wouldn't say one blanket statement I
think they'd be very limiting but it
does represent a certain kind of freedom
for me and a certain kind of openness
and a decluttering and rule number ten
the last one before the bonuses and also
my personal favorite empower others Col
simply berry is a lifestyle brand no
question it's about philosophy it's
about encouraging women not intimidating
them that should be very intimidating if
you encourage women to explore their own
creativity and hopefully you'll give
them the tools they can express
themselves a beautiful print a great
gene that's beautifully cut then I think
we're on the right track so I love rule
number 10 empower others because it
really speaks to the one word philosophy
and core selling in that people are
buying you and your products because of
what you stand for and because of how it
makes them feel about themselves it's a
reflection of themselves not just
because of the benefits that they're
getting by using your product so
companies often start off selling the
the features what your product or
service actually does then they move
towards benefit selling which is more
around the benefit that they get by
using your product or service and then
the companies that really excel the
companies that have brand status the
companies that are really doing big
things are the ones using core selling
which is that last bit which is by using
your product or service by being
associated with your company I feel
better about myself I feel empowered
myself to go off and do something
because I believe not just in the
product you're selling but in the
mission of your business and then you
get to the point where people will buy
from you just because of who you are and
what you're doing regardless of what the
product or service actually is and so
that's where I want companies to go to
that's why I want entrepreneurs to be
not just competing on price but
competing on your mission if you're
doing something really important and you
want that to spread and you want that to
be the thing the catalyst that makes
people want to come
I can buy from you and tell their
friends about you and keep buying from
you and keep telling more people about
you so I love it I love the idea of
empowering others I encourage all
entrepreneurs to find that empowering
mission within yourself your one word
bring that to your business and that's
when you start to see a lot of success
so I wanna know from you guys though
rule number 10 was my personal favorite
do you agree with me is rule number 10
the best one from this episode or is a
rule that you like better let me know
leave it down the comments below
now I made this video because Fanny
Mitzi asked me to if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next check out the link in the
description to the request line where
you can go and cast your vote I also
want to give a quick shout out to Lin PO
daddy Lin thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my new book the top 10
rules to success and sharing it with
your kids and having them read it at a
young age I love it I love that picture
thank you for posting it online and for
all the support so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon
I was quite inspired by fictitious
Merion Winnett this last show I gave and
ready-to-wear was based on Mary onto a
new version of her a new vision of her
if she were today because she was a
fashion icon to me I mean her dress has
got larger her hairdos her pen loop got
bigger and bigger her wigs and she she
became a rock star in fashion and I
wasn't really looking at the beheading
or for all over the end of the monarchy
I was really looking at her as this
fashion this fashion adventurous you
know and I mean that she dared she
really dared to explore new proportion
was silhouette I looked at it from a
very weird point from a fashion point of
view so I would love to know what went
through her head when she went to live
in the country and suddenly she was
wearing these peasant shirts and
sleeping in them and and she left the
court you know of Louis says and
suddenly she's like this country girl
I guess what there is that the economy
and most women they're there many sides
to one woman you're not just one thing
you're many things and that's why I
thought it was kind of fascinating this
year for me to explore her mindset at
least what I think was her mindset
[Music]
ever if you have to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple that would be to like a
little beacon they believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]